[inaudible]
joining me today is the original king of interviewing,
a friend,
a mentor,
a living legend,
and a man who loves good Brooklyn Water Bagel.
Larry King.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
No one ever I hear legend.
I think one thing old.
Well,
and every time we've sat down,
I always,
I feel that I have to say living legend at the beginning because who are you are
like you are.
One of the best compliments I ever got was Derek Jeter.
Great Yankee.
Now over the Marlins came over to me at the All star game some years ago and
said,
you,
he said there were a lot of phony legends.
You're a true luxury.
Wow.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
That warm my heart.
And that's coming from alleging cause that guy care guys,
the true baseball every too.
Did you ever think that after all your years in radio,
in Cable News now doing the digital thing,
that you'd be sitting in a garage being interviewed like this,
going out to hundreds of thousands and millions of people?
Well,
let me tell you the truth.
We're opening,
this is the pinnacle of my career.
If you'd have told me 61 years ago when I started,
61 years from today,
you will be known around the world.
You'll be called an icon,
no living legend.
And at the height of your career,
you'll be in a garage with David Rubin.
It's come full circle.
You're killing me,
Larry.
David.
But what does that,
what does that say about just how everything has changed?
I mean,
the
only thing sure is change.
The only thing constant is change.
When I started in radio,
we had land lines.
Uh,
went through a phone line.
I did start in radio,
did local television one year after I started ordering.
Always did both.
Always regarded both equally.
Uh,
I always thought of television as radio with pictures.
We could be on the radio now.
Yeah.
But we released this as an audio.
I know,
but they don't have to see it.
Yeah.
Um,
we could imagine,
and he's radio is theater of the mind,
but I always took it as just communicating.
So I started in radio,
then did local television,
then the national radio and satellites.
I was there when satellites were introduced.
I never forgot it.
I'm in Washington.
The guest is in La and it feels like he's right there.
Yeah,
right there.
It was amazing satellite.
And I said satellites.
That's the end that completed.
And Ted Turner hired me through CNN and I'm seeing around the world.
We go up 23,000 miles to go next door and to Moscow.
Try to explain that to Jefferson.
I'm doing that.
And now after 22 almost 26 years at CNN,
61 years in the business,
I thought I could retire.
Carlos slim came along and said,
we gotta do something.
So the internet or a TV Hulu.
Who knew from this?
Yeah.
And when you tell me about the Internet,
what bugs me is when hill is it?
Where is the Internet?
And people thought about the Internet and I even though just have to accept it
like correct.
I'm a product of all these things,
but basically David,
yeah.
I am doing exactly what I did 61 years ago.
What this,
what we're doing right now is no different.
Yeah,
we're being delivered differently.
But what we're doing,
it's no different.
What does that say about this?
The ability to sit across from somebody,
look them in the eye and actually try to understand the human experience.
Cause I was saying to you in the green room right before there is a massive
renaissance right now because of podcasts,
about long form conversation.
The thing that you've been doing for 60 some odd,
but that's where it's happening in podcasts.
Yeah.
It's not happening on television.
Not even on cable toe.
They used to call,
you know MSNBC,
CNN and Fox News shuttles.
They're not news channels.
They have trumped channels is pro Trump ones.
Anti Trump won sometimes hate Trump and there's pundits.
Yeah,
it's 24 hours a day of punditry.
They do not cover the news.
When the hurricane was hitting Carolina,
it was in a box on the corner of the screen.
While they were talking about Trump.
You saw where the hurricane was.
That's not news.
Do you remember seeing a change on that because you were at CNN?
Do you remember what year you started at the end?
I started,
of course you're well,
1985 and left in 2010 yeah.
Do you remember seeing something changing in the way the news reported and the
way they saw it when the other side started?
You know,
we owned it for a while.
CNN.
Yeah,
and then it was MSNBC and Fox and we thought they were little invaders.
Ted Turner was a genius.
Yeah,
an office pants.
Genius of the seat of the pants.
He was driving in a car one day and the guy said all news all the time.
He said,
why I could not work on television?
Then he puts it up on the big bird.
Look what he,
he is the revolutionary leader of the second half of the 20th century.
Changes the world and look where it's come to that Internet dire everywhere,
you know,
the different side.
There's good and bad to it.
If something happened in the world right now,
David,
everyone knows it in a minute,
in a minute.
The world knows it.
Wow.
Yeah.
What do we do with this?
To end with.
Technology is always ahead of the human advance.
So when technology's ahead,
it's how do we grasp using this.
It's a great pie.
Interviewed Steve Jobs when he started apple and I'm wondering if he were here
today,
if he would know what an impact that's had in the world.
Cause I've had experts told me that your iPhone will control your life.
Basically is controlling our lives right now.
This is,
that's a perfect segway,
my friend.
Can you bust out your phone?
I do not have an iPhone because I don't want to be,
I was addicted to tobacco from age 17 to age 53 when I had a heart attack.
I know what addiction is.
I would wake up in the morning and grabbed the cigarette before I put my glasses
on.
Anything.
I see people,
my wife,
friends with their cell phones.
I have dinner with a friend I'd ever talked to him.
We sit at then and I mean,
and he's,
yeah,
I think they get thumb cancer.
So I have old school.
A flip phone.
His phone.
Yeah.
It's a phone.
Put it to your ear.
You hear the other side?
I don't text.
I hit people.
They call me.
I called them normal.
You're the only person that I actually call.
You do realize that I don't call anybody.
I just tech.
Why wouldn't you?
Why you see this hurts me.
You as a broadcaster.
As a communicator.
Yeah.
Why do you text?
Oh,
I can see an emergency.
I'm stuck.
I'll be late.
Yeah,
but come on.
Sometimes Steve got paypal it.
Well look,
you know,
this is what I love to do,
but sometimes just for the sake of ease of just,
you know,
I'm going to be here then or I'll see you there.
You know a lot of that.
I try not to have long form discussions about political views,
but yeah,
people are fighting over personal things on there and all of that.
But wait,
I want,
I want it back at the thing you said before because,
so when the satellites started and then you've suddenly,
we're doing interviews with people where you weren't in the same room,
do you remember that affecting the interview in any way?
Cause I always like this.
I don't know.
There's nothing like that.
Nothing beats this.
Yeah.
Nothing.
However,
I always try to treat it as this.
They just weren't there,
so I tried to make eye contact via the satellite.
I tried to treat it as if they were there and when I got used to handling well
and enjoyed was when I'd have five different guests in five different places.
Yeah,
and controlling that.
Yeah.
And then I did diplomacy.
I had a night where we had a Arafat Rabin
and a
king.
The king of Jordan.
Yeah.
Can your dog though his father.
Okay.
All three.
Kissinger told me you're doing diplomacy.
Yeah.
I had Arafat,
King of Jordan and the prime minister of Israel
together.
Me a little Jewish kid from Brooklyn sitting there by satellite,
but I felt I was with them.
Yeah.
I didn't treat it as them being there.
I treated it as like this.
Yeah.
Did you in,
in some of the bigger interviews that you did over the years,
I mean,
you've interviewed,
you've truly interviewed everybody.
Is there anyone that you felt like you didn't,
you didn't get that
kill Castro?
I went down to Cuba in 19 in 2009 two oh nine I was treated regally.
They all wonderful to me,
but I couldn't nail it.
I couldn't get them to do.
I was fascinated by him because he led his country longer than any leader in
memory.
Somebody had to like them.
Right.
Even if it was only one person,
and then when I went to Havana,
I never saw a happier country.
I was amazed.
The people smiling,
musical hotels,
mobbed,
you know,
from Canadians and Germans and beautiful weather,
beautiful city water.
Havana ought to be open to everybody.
It's beautiful.
The water's up or just,
it's a great city.
How aware were you when you're interviewing big timers,
the real movers and shakers that the ravines in our fats that you mentioned,
that something that you ask them could actually turn the course of history?
Yeah,
I'm not aware of,
I know a lot of it did.
I know the parole go debate change Nafta.
We Clinton called me up the next day and say you pass enough to,
that was way behind until the goal or pro debate.
You try not to read it as a,
but once,
once the light goes on,
that's just the moment I'm in.
You know his eye.
If I'm sitting with Jimmy Carter or a ballet dancer,
once the light goes on,
I'm in that moment.
I don't think about yesterday.
Can't do anything about it.
Don't think about tomorrow.
That's tomorrow.
So I'm in the now,
so I'm right in this now.
You should be in this now.
So if you've got Trump coming tomorrow and you're thinking about that,
then you're losing this moment.
I'm here,
I always treat,
I focused.
Do you,
I think that that your curiosity,
do you think you sort of made that for yourself or was it built into you?
Because I've been out with you to lunch or to dinner,
breakfast,
whatever it is,
and I can see you're as curious about the waiter busboy or sometimes when we
were at Ora together and you'd be chatting with,
you know,
the guy doing the lights or whatever,
that you were actually as interested in them as if was that.
Hello David.
I remember as a kid getting on a bus kids and asking the bus driver,
why do you want to drive a bus?
I remember we'd go to ballgames,
kid in Brooklyn and go to dodger games.
Go with my friends.
We'd wait outside for the players.
They wanted autographs.
I never wanted an autograph.
Want that?
Ask questions.
I would run along that a player going into his car.
Why did,
why did you bunt?
Why'd you do that?
That I was always a wide person.
Yeah.
I'm the kind of person you don't want to sit next to on an airplane.
I I'm in and I don't know where that came from but it's the best gift I got was
security I the gift of curiosity.
Anthony Quinn told me that you have the greatest gift ever.
Curiosity.
My friend Herby Cohen who wrote,
you can negotiate anything,
says to me the secret of my success is being stupid.
He didn't mean that demeaning.
Basically what you're doing is saying,
help me,
help me with this wind.
You do that.
Someone asked me if you had interviewed Osama bin Laden,
what were your first question?
Had been,
well it would not have been.
Why did you bombed the World Trade Center?
It would have been
you grew up in one of the richest families in Saudi Arabia.
Why you leave
now?
He probably hadn't thought of that since he left.
Yeah,
but it forces you to think and then I'm going to learn more about him before I
learned about the bombing.
And also you have to understand that nobody,
nobody thinks they're evil.
Hitler did not comb his hair in the morning and say,
I am a bad person.
They may be crazy,
but they believe nobody thinks far.
I'm really terrible.
And everyone has an excuse for what they do.
The bankrupt that bank by my father,
they charged his checking account that screwed them and the public funding
enough at Myers,
the renegade,
Dylan.
Joe was very popular in America.
Very popular.
He robbed from banks who likes banks.
Right.
So how do you then interview a bad dude?
Someone that's got you curious.
You're curious about a bad dude.
I try not to.
It's hard.
Sometimes racist especially.
Yeah,
I had a tough time doing the early George Wallace.
The later George Wallace who was terrific.
The early George was,
I had a tough time because I don't understand racism.
I've never understood it.
Yeah.
I don't have no understanding of why someone would have different pigment.
That's all it is.
Should be treated differently.
You think that comes from just growing up in Brooklyn and everything's,
whenever we set you,
can you,
can you just talk about that a little bit?
Like what that was like growing up?
Oh,
I grew up in a neighborhood of mixed,
you know,
Jews,
Protestants,
Catholics and that's it.
We had some blacks,
not a lot,
but blacks went to school with us.
When I went down to Miami to break into radio,
I was 23 and I got off the train and the first thing I saw were two water
fountains,
colored white.
I drank out of the colored.
Yeah.
I never seen anything like that.
You grew up in Brooklyn?
That was beyond me.
Then I got on a bus to go over to Miami beach to stay with my uncle and the bus
drivers stops the bus and asked me to move forward because the back is for
blacks
and I said to him,
my father's black,
I'll stay in the back.
So I know I never understood it.
And I've asked this a racist.
I have never understood why a white feels superior to a black.
Lenny Bruce,
who was a great friend of mine,
used to tell me that the human being has to have something to hate that drives
him because they have an inferiority complex.
So they have to feel superior to something.
And he told me 40 years ago,
Sunday blacks will get equal rights and we'll have to hate something.
I'll tell you what,
we'll hate Eskimos as Zoe is another.
Right?
In other words,
you know,
used to check into a hotel and underneath the chair would be assigned,
remove under penalty of law.
You know who removes them?
Eskimos,
you know,
and he Eskimo war heroes.
Yeah.
You don't know name one.
I can't.
I'm going to have to go.
I'm going to Google that.
Got An Eskimo doctor know that they would look for,
they would just try to find and racism always be fuddle.
I interviewed Dean Rusk,
secretary of State Kennedy years,
and he was a very progressive southerner from Georgia.
His daughter married a black man.
He has,
he said,
I have no prejudice.
Themeless they taught me a little about prejudice.
So did Malcolm X.
Dean Rusk said to me,
my daughter married a black man.
I have black grandchildren.
I have no prejudice.
I got on a commercial plane.
The pilot was black and for a minute I was nervous.
That shows you how inbred it can be.
Yeah.
Can he fly the plane?
But I've never,
it boggles me
when you win over the years when you've talked to some of these people,
you know,
white supremacists,
they're just some of these people that come from that truly racist place.
Okay.
Did you ever hear them saying anything?
Was it almost like therapy in a way that you felt if you talk to them long
enough,
maybe they could get out of it?
Did you ever sense,
I try.
You try you to try to administer.
You can notice some books out by former white supremacists who come full circle.
If of course they raised a lot to do with raising as their major inferiority
complex.
You got to deal with that.
Although someone said it's not a complex tear inferior.
Who are some of the people that you interviewed that uh,
that you think either it went the wrong way or any regrets in never sitting down
with somebody to go,
Oh man,
I missed that mall.
I can tell you one is the one trying to remember his name now.
The guy who succeeded Steve Jobs,
they want immediate while Tim Cook now,
but it's not at all.
Yeah,
Steve Jobs hired him.
Oh,
what was his name?
Bright Guy came from Pepsi Cola or I think I'll have my guys go with a little
while and he ran,
he ran and I had them on for two hours.
Yeah.
Great guest now.
And why was it wise?
NIAC is that [inaudible] was with this partner.
Okay.
Oh,
this guy,
we're play a joined the cooperation.
Steve left out,
then came back later.
Okay.
We'll,
we'll grab it.
So I spend two hours interviewing.
This guy was great,
all about previous jobs and then I finish and now I go to Kohl's.
I used to do this on my old lady or show two hour interview Lauer calls in an
open phone America.
I go to close the first call.
Larry.
Steve jobs fired him.
Yeah,
he replaced Steve Jobs and then Steve jobs fired him.
You didn't even ask about that
shit or no.
Yeah.
It's tough when one gets by it.
Right.
And it haunts you.
Look at out is years ago is still haunts him.
You try to know everything.
You can't,
there's no perfect interview.
You can't know everything.
You do the best she can.
I had a tough time with Ahmadinejad other ran because he would lie.
Remember he was talking to me.
John Scully I think is the guys.
It John's Scalese.
We've got to crack team over.
There you go.
He's still around.
By the way,
when I interviewed,
I'm at dinner,
John,
and we're talking about various things and we're talking about the Holocaust
and he says to me as why you always have to listen when you're doing an
interview.
He said,
if there was a holocaust,
why isn't Israel in Poland?
That's where the crime occurred.
Why is the state of Israel 2000 miles away?
There was no crime in Palestine.
The crime was in Poland and Germany.
Why didn't they take that area and give it the Israel?
Right.
It made some sense.
You could argue with logically.
Yeah.
I said to him,
did you say if there was a while ago?
Yes.
Right there.
Are you saying if I,
you know,
when we got contentious,
you denying the Holocaust?
It was those are,
but look,
I've had so many years doing this,
Dave and I can't explain how I still love it.
I love the interplay.
Yeah.
You should love what you do.
Know why you're learning something every day,
every day.
So I can't be close minded like I'm a liberal politically,
certainly in social issues,
but I'm not closed minded enough to think that you can have an opposing view.
I liked the argument,
I liked the discussion,
but in interviewing,
I never,
I mean my ego at the door,
I try not to use the word I to relevant and I tried to get into walk in
together.
You know Edward Bennett Williams,
a great lawyer,
told me once,
I said,
what is the role of the criminal defense lawyer?
He said to get one person on the jury to walk in your client's shoes.
If you can get one person to walk in your client's shoes,
got a hung jury.
All he has to do is say,
I would've done that.
Yeah.
When you were doing five nights a week and on any good,
I use this example a lot
because people will say,
oh Dave,
you had this,
you know,
this bad person on or this that.
The other thing I'll say,
you know what?
In Larry King's Day,
let's go 1992 CNN,
you'd have the cast of friends on Monday.
You'd have an Oj Simpson lawyer on Tuesday,
you'd have,
you know,
an animal guy on Wednesday,
you'd have,
you know,
a doctor on,
on Thursday and then you know,
former secretary of state on Friday.
Was that crazy for you?
You just love the bounce or part of my curiosity?
Yeah,
most of the Times.
Most of the Times driving in,
I didn't know I had on that night.
Really?
I still don't the Laura,
I drive in.
I don't know who's on,
unless it were really someone famous,
like we might have the animal guy.
I didn't know it was called until I walk in and see all the animals and because
my curiosity comes from pure curiosity.
So where your guy's hands and you know,
no,
I get a blue car.
Like do you have loom?
I had a blue car.
Facts.
Yeah.
He was secretary of state from yesteryear that year.
He was responsible for the Marshall Plan.
Right.
That's all.
And then I would do the things that had the Marshall Plan come about.
Yeah.
How we're part of it.
Did you play with George Marshall?
Was his plan where you in on the thinking,
you know,
it's all when,
when we have the go for,
I would see other shows in which the guests would come on and be a general or
something and the host would say today and the Gulf War,
1000 people were killed.
And the thing that now terrain is here and all I would say is what happened?
What happened today?
Because he has the perspective.
If you have an interview where you turn the TV on and the host is on more than
the guest,
something's wrong.
If you,
if it takes you three sentences to ask a question,
something's wrong.
Because a lot of them are show offs.
I'll give you the show off interviewer,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
I guess today is Dave Ruben.
He's written a new book.
Paul Chicago,
my hometown.
Been great to have you here.
Dave.
You know I visited Chicago many times.
Always love going there.
Did you do,
do you write about the,
the stock yard [inaudible] stock.
He has a fascinating,
do you ever go there folks?
In other words,
you are a prop for me and that's gone now though.
There aren't even low shows anymore.
Yeah.
What do you make of,
so when you left CNN,
I,
I've said this to you before you left in 2010 it seems to me you can do a pretty
clean line between you leaving CNN.
Obviously the Piers Morgan thing didn't work out.
If you want to comment on that you can,
but that you were one of the people that people trusted.
There's almost no one in news or on television anymore that people go,
oh,
like no one was walking around.
And even the people that maybe didn't like it that much,
they were going to Larry King's a bad dude.
Larry King's a liar.
You know what I mean?
Nobody was doing that by having one of the main faces who had been there for so
long.
I really think it broke something in the continuity of CNN that kind of led us
to where we are now.
Related to all the cable,
maybe.
Maybe it did.
There were signs,
you know,
Fox News was beating us.
We had one at all those years.
And Fox News,
who speeding is beating CNN the day beating us at night.
That was a sign.
This was a network.
That's not news,
but am I making this up?
When you left CNN,
you still at the highest rated show?
The second highest we,
we started a fall,
not precipitously,
but we started a fall.
We saw it.
We sort of see and sort from per say,
soda,
you know,
CNN always made a ton of money,
which they would have first and everybody in America had.
CNN paid 50 cents a month.
So Ted,
turn out that in on a genius.
Thinking of this right now,
you and I are paying for CNN.
We're not watching it.
You don't pay for CVS.
You pay him for CNN.
He knew it.
So CNN made money.
If they had no commercials but didn't do anything just beyond public tune,
then
it's a different world now.
I can't,
I don't know.
Maybe it was the cleavage.
You know Jerry Seinfeld said,
my old column I used to do in USA today when I did,
it's my 2 cents.
That was the beginning of Twitter.
Yeah.
Really quick comments.
Uh,
but I,
you know,
people call me a pioneer,
so I,
all I see myself is I'm a lucky Jewish kid from Brooklyn who was curious and
that curiosity into a career as I was able to take the natural curiosity and
make a career of it.
You think we're maybe running out of that?
When you,
when you talk to younger,
you have to be very young sons.
When you talk to young people,
watch how they get the news.
You were telling me about kids with the phones and everything and you've,
you love the newspaper,
right?
You are
the New York Times.
Like I got an Iphone,
they gave me an iPhone,
so I use it to get baseball scores.
Yeah.
That's all.
I don't you,
I don't have it with me.
Yeah.
I don't need it.
The games that tonight,
uh,
you go right.
You're,
I mean,
you're a major still a dodger.
Oh yeah.
I love the game.
I though I'd go to basketball.
I love competition.
Your gradient at dodger stadium right now,
I tell you why.
I love sports.
Sports is the ones,
you're not a sports fan.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
The best thing about being a sports fan,
it's,
it's the one thing in your life when you get up in the morning,
you know who's going to win,
so you have something to look forward to,
good or bad.
You don't know who's going to win.
Nobody wakes up at that except sports fans.
Another thing,
what I love about athletes,
maybe more than any profession,
their career is over and other careers or beginning,
they have that day when the cheering stops.
Imagine what that's like.
You build yourself up in your 37 years old.
They'd paid you all this money for doing what you did as a kid,
and another thing the athlete has that we don't have.
Final score can argue that's it.
Eight to seven you lost.
You got seven,
they got eight.
You can say,
yeah,
but they should stop.
You've got seven they got.
Now if you've got eight,
you get the applause.
You get the down.
You get that every day.
Recognition.
Nonrecognition walked down the street
athletes,
so I love,
I'm so,
I love all it brings all my curiosity sports,
bring it to a head because I'm always interested in
last night the Dodgers was,
he left a lefthander into pixis right handed bat.
He's got all those pictures in the dugout.
Why did even,
why did he leave him in?
Did you find there was something unique about the top of the line athletes that
you would talk to you that they,
that they genuinely had something different?
You guys didn't have
confidence.
Yeah,
that's it.
Stan Musial,
the grape cardinal outfielder,
Wally west Lake was a teammate of his and he,
while they told me this story,
it's,
they're sitting in a dug out before a game and Westlake those over the museum
said,
Stan,
I got up this morning,
breakfast was great,
the show was great to drive in was great and in batting practice I've hit five
home runs.
I feel great.
You ever had that kind of Day Stan?
And he said,
every
that's as good as they get.
The quarterback who throws 10 incomplete passes,
never thinks about the 11th flow.
To have the 10 incomplete effect.
Him Confidence.
They have that ability.
You take wide receivers in football,
they're all fast.
They all have good hands.
The great ones,
the great ones,
they Bowlby,
it's coming.
Gretzky told me he saw the puck go into the goal before it went into the corner.
It's a a,
so I have great appreciation.
I also have appreciation for politicians.
They do something we don't do.
They have a first Tuesday in November.
You don't have that day.
You didn't have a first Tuesday in November.
They win and lose.
They stand up before the public and they win.
They lose.
They get rejected.
Jimmy Carter telling me the saddest day of his life was flying home from his
last appearance when his advisors told them,
you know,
they know in the afternoon.
Yeah,
you're going to lose.
The great story of Barbara Bush told me when George Bush loss to Bill Clinton at
three o'clock in the afternoon,
and they knew he was going to lose,
and they're all sitting around Samba and Bob Mover.
She came in and said,
where do we get a driver's license?